hello everybody this is Gary Vaynerchuk
and this is my 120 and don't look now
but guess who is hot again Microsoft you
might have noticed that the stock is
jumping up and yesterday I was sick
watching a fox new business channel
which was kind of cool and I was like
you know Microsoft Microsoft and I
bought some shares and it did real well
actually after the closing reports and
why he did it and because of a lot of
different things number one Microsoft as
you might have heard only about a 1.6
percent investment into Facebook on a 15
billion dollar valuation so yes that may
bite them in the ass
however we are talking about a company
with tons of cash and no Dennis
healthiest any of them out there plus
what Microsoft has going on and if they
were smart enough to take a cue from
Apple and changed their business model
like Apple did by becoming a music
provider with the iPod and all those
things are now moving into the phone
space if Microsoft wasn't so stubborn
and called itself a computer company and
started calling itself maybe like
Facebook a technology company they would
get a lot more serious because a lot of
what's caught Microsoft excited and
everybody excited about Microsoft is the
halo 3 sales and if they would focus
more on being a software game developer
and getting more into that space and
more importantly use some of their cash
on buying an asset that's undervalued I
don't know maybe Yahoo Microsoft can get
very sexy very quickly you know it's
very funny kind of like Disney and
McDonald's there's been a lot of
companies that have researched after
changing a little bit and going in a
different direction I think some new
blood at Microsoft if they can have a
you know Steve's ear a little bit and
whisper in their Stevie B needs to
change the road just a little bit and
Microsoft can become America's darling
once again cuz don't look now but if
you're spending time in the valley
Google's rank is kind of going down
there's street cred and believe in not
the big gorilla that everybody hated
Microsoft is starting creep a little up